right 2.75 as a simplified fraction so
once you get some practice here you're
going to find it pretty straightforward
to do but we're really gonna think
through it and get the intuition for why
this makes sense so if we were to write
this down the two that literally just
represents 2/1 so I'll just write it
down like that then we have the seven in
the MU that in another color we have a
seven one place to the right of the
decimal it's in the tenths place with a
ths at the end at tenth place so it
literally represents seven over ten and
then finally we have the five in the
hundredths place so it represents five
over 100 now if I want to write this as
a simplified fraction or really as a
mixed number I have to merge these
fractional parts right here and to add
two fractions you have to have a common
denominator and to figure out the common
denominator you just have to think about
the least common multiple of ten and a
hundred and that's 100 they 100 is
divisible by both 110 so let's get this
10 to be a hundred so we can do that by
multiplying it by 10 so when you
multiply something by 10 you add a zero
at the end of it but you can't just do
that to the denominator we also have to
do that to the numerator so we
multiplied the denominator by 10 let's
also multiply the numerator by 10 7
times 10 is 70 or 70 or 100 it's the
exact same thing as 7/10 now we can add
these two what is 70 plus 5 70 plus 5 is
75 and our denominator is 100 so this
can be re-written as 2 + 70 75
hundredths and we saw that in the last
video you would read this as 2 and 75
hundredths now we aren't in a completely
simplified fraction yet because 75 and a
hundred have common factors and the
largest number that goes into both if
you're familiar with quarters is a
twenty five twenty three quarters is 75
cents four quarters is 100 cents or four
quarters is a dollar so let's me divide
both of them by 25
so 75/25 is three and a hundred divided
by 25 is four so as a simplified mixed
number this becomes 2 and 3/4 and after
you do a lot of practice here and you
just see a lot of numbers like this will
be almost second nature for you to say
Oh 2.75 is the same thing as 2 and 75
hundredths is the same thing as 2 and
3/4